look very impressive black's knight not
the best piece in the world anymore
that's true a moral moral victory it's a
moral victory
let's have a look
symbolic at best but okay we did predict
it the black knight drops back i wish i
had a pound for every time we predicted
to move lines yeah okay well hang on a
second
magnus is in a peaceful mood he doesn't
want to continue the game these rooks
are about to leave the board let's go
back to the players because we could see
a result any moment now
and uh
will we see that handshake
magnus playing on brook takes rook and
knight will recapture and draw any
second now will they will they offer
they can now they can i know
40 of them
i think you might be right because
unless yan has said something
unless tiana said something to offer the
draw
it's move 41
yay
i like my points in the prediction
challenge yep
let's hear what's uh been said in the
venue
nothing so far oh that's the first
nothing to say
very solid game by both players
not much to discuss no critical moments
necessarily just very very
solid performance wow